[Music]
the coldest materials in the world
aren't in Antarctica they're not at the
top of Mount Everest or buried in a
glacier they're in physics labs clouds
of gases help just fractions of a degree
above absolute zero
that's 395 million times colder than
your refrigerator a hundred million
times colder than liquid nitrogen and
four million times colder than outer
space temperatures this low gives
scientists a window into the inner
workings of matter and allow engineers
to build incredibly sensitive
instruments that tell us more about
everything from our exact position on
the planet to what's happening in the
farthest reaches of the universe how do
we create such extreme temperatures in
short by slowing down moving particles
when we're talking about temperature
what we're really talking about is
motion the atoms that make up solids
liquids and gases are moving all the
time
when atoms are moving more rapidly we
perceive that matter as hot when they're
moving more slowly we perceive it as
cold to make a hot object or gas cold in
everyday life we place it in a colder
environment like a refrigerator some of
the atomic motion in the hot object is
transferred to the surroundings and it
cools down but there's a limit to this
even outer space is too warm to create
ultra-low temperatures so instead
scientists figured out a way to slow the
atoms down directly with a laser beam
under most circumstances the energy and
a laser beam heats things up but used in
a very precise way the beams momentum
can stall moving atoms cooling them down
that's what happens in a device called a
magneto-optical trap atoms are injected
into a vacuum chamber and a magnetic
field draws them towards the center a
laser beam aimed at the middle of the
chamber is tuned to just the right
frequency that an atom moving towards it
will absorb a photon of the laser beam
and slow down the slow down effect comes
from the transfer of momentum between
the atom and the photon a total of six
beams in a perpendicular arrangement
ensure that atoms traveling in all
directions will be intercepted at
Center where the beams intersect the
atoms move sluggishly as if trapped in a
thick liquid and effect the researchers
who invented it described as optical
molasses a magneto-optical trap like
this can cool atoms down to just a few
micro kelvins about negative 273 degrees
Celsius this technique was developed in
the 1980s and the scientist who
contributed to it won the Nobel Prize in
Physics in 1997 for the discovery since
then laser cooling has been improved to
reach even lower temperatures but why
would you want to cool atoms down that
much
first of all cold atoms can make very
good detectors with so little energy
they're incredibly sensitive to
fluctuations in the environment so
they're used in devices that find
underground oil and mineral deposits and
they also make highly accurate atomic
clocks like the ones used in global
positioning satellites secondly cold
atoms hold enormous potential for
probing the frontiers of physics their
extreme sensitivity makes them
candidates to be used to detect
gravitational waves in future
space-based detectors they're also
useful for the study of atomic and
subatomic phenomenon which requires
measuring incredibly tiny fluctuations
in the energy of atoms those are drowned
out at normal temperatures when atoms
speed around at hundreds of meters per
second laser cooling can slow atoms to
just a few centimeters per second enough
for the motion caused by atomic quantum
effects to become obvious ultra cold
atoms have already allowed scientists to
study phenomena like bose-einstein
condensation in which atoms are cooled
almost absolute zero and become a rare
new state of matter so as researchers
continue in their quest to understand
the laws of physics and unravel the
mysteries of the universe though do so
with the help of the very coldest atoms
in it for more brain-busting physics
check out this playlist of videos that
we created in collaboration with CERN
scientists
[Music]